MUCH MORE IN THAT COMING UP.
SCHUMER, BILL de BLASIO,
FORMAL, FAILED, ALL OF THEM.
FACTS WITHOUT FEAR, OVER 7,600
VENTILATORS HAVE BEEN DISTURBED
AND NOW NATIONWIDE.
IT IS GOING TO THE AREAS THAT
NEEDED MOST.
IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ALSO DEVOTED A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
L.A. IS NOW FACING A CRISIS OF
ITS OWN AS THE CITY’S SKID ROW
HAS NOW CONFIRMED THEIR FIRST
CASE OF CORONAVIRUS.
THIS IS A HUGE POTENTIAL PROBLEM
OUT IN CALIFORNIA AS OFFICIALS
RIGHTLY WORRYING THAT THAT VIRUS
COULD RIP THROUGH L.A.’S AND
NORMA’S HOMELESS POPULATION.
I LIVED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
FOR FIVE YEARS.
IT’S A VERY LARGE POPULATION.
MEANWHILE, WITH VITAL MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT RUNNING LOW
NATIONWIDE, THE FBI -- LOOK AT
THIS -- THEY SEIZED NEARLY
200,000 N95 MASKS, 598,000
MEDICAL GRADE GLOVES, 130,000
SURGICAL MASKS FROM PEOPLE
HOARDING THE SUPPLIES.
SADLY, A SMALL PERCENTAGE WE SEE
THE WORST IN PEOPLE.
THIS COMES AS THE VERY FIRST
WAVE OF THE N95 MASK FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD IS FINALLY
REACHING THE U.S.
THESE ARE THE FIRST MAJOR
SHIPMENTS SINCE FEBRUARY AND
THIS, BY THE WAY BRINGS US TO
FACTS THAT SHOULD CONCERN EVERY
AMERICAN TONIGHT.
YOU NEED TO KNOW WHAT TO PROTECT
YOURSELF AND YOUR FAMILY.
MULTIPLE BREAKING NEWS REPORTS
ON MANY FRONTS.
TONIGHT, THE VERY FIRST TIME, WE
NOW SEE MORE THAN A THOUSAND
AMERICANS HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES
TO THIS PANDEMIC IN ONE 24-HOUR
SPAN.
SO FAR CLOSE TO 6,000 AMERICANS
HAVE PASSED AWAY FROM THIS
VIRUS.
THAT INCLUDES OVER 2,000
NEW YORKERS AND WE HAVE TO STOP,
IMAGINE HOW MUCH WORSE THIS
WOULD HAVE BEEN IF WE DIDN’T
HAVE THE TRAVEL BAN TEN DAYS
AFTER THE FIRST KNOWN CASE IN
THE UNITED STATES AND THE
FOLLOWING QUARANTINE.
IN SUBSEQUENT TRAVEL BAN’S.
TODAY THE PENTAGON CONFIRMED
THEY ARE LOOKING TO PURCHASE
100,000 BODY BAGS.
THE CDC IS NOW REPORTING THAT
THOSE INFECTED WITH CORONAVIRUS
THAT SPREAD THE ILLNESS FOR 1-3
DAYS BEFORE SHOWING ANY
SYMPTOMS, I WAS TALKING ABOUT
THIS VERY EARLY, I HAVE THAT ON
Hannity.com IF YOU WANT TO SEE
IT, AND ONE FOR LUMINARY STUDY
FOUND THAT THE VIRUS HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO TRAVEL THROUGH THE
AIR.
WELL, DR. OZ WILL WEIGH IN ON
THAT TONIGHT AND PART OF OUR
MEDICAL INFORMATION FOR YOUR
FAMILY AND ANOTHER STUDY FOUND A
SMALL GROUP OF CORONAVIRUS
PATIENTS EXHIBITING NEUROLOGICAL
SYMPTOMS.
THE FALLOUT FROM THE VIRUS IS
NOT DELIVERING A SERIOUS BLOW TO
THE ECONOMY AS WELL.
PREDICTABLE, STILL HARD TO HEAR.
LAST WEEK, 6.6 MILLION AMERICANS
FIRED FOR FILED FOR AN
APPOINTMENT.
ALL-TIME RECORD.
OVER THE PAST TWO WEEKS MORE
THAN 10 MILLION AMERICANS HAVE
FILED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT.
NOT SURPRISING, BUT IT’S HARD.
NOT EVERY INDUSTRY IS STRUGGLING
HOWEVER.
ALCOHOL SALES WENT UP BY 50%.
I DON’T BLAME ANY OF YOU.
NOW LET’S GET TO THE GOOD NEWS
TONIGHT.
SOME HOPE THAT BRINGS US HOPE
AND THAT IS A LOT TO COVER
THERE.
IN A TIME OF CRISIS IT IS
AMAZING, BECAUSE YOU SEE THE
BEST OF AMERICA, WHICH IS THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS, CHINESE ARE BRIGHTER
THAN EVER.
IF DOCTORS NURSES, SCIENTISTS,
RESEARCHERS, MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS.
JANITORS AND HOSPITALS.
EVERYONE IN THE MEDICAL FIELD,
HEROIC WORK.
IF THEY OUR THANKS TONIGHT AND
THE SUPPLIES THEY SO DESPERATELY
NEED.
TO THAT END, WE HAVE NEW ENGLAND
PATRIOTS OWNER, OUR FRIEND
ROBERT KRAFT.
HE JUST USED THE TEAM PLANE TO
IMPORT 1.2 MILLION N95 MASKS
FROM CHINA TO THE UNITED STATES.
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER, WELL, HE
DESERVES TO BE CONGRATULATED
TONIGHT.
$1 MILLION IN MASKS AND OTHER
GEAR TO HOSPITAL WORKERS.
YOU KNOW THE TV SHOW, "THE
MASKED SINGER"?
THEY DONATED 10,000 SURGICAL
MASKS TO NEW YORK HOSPITALS.
DOLLY PARTON DONATED A MILLION
DOLLARS PER CORONAVIRUS
RESEARCH.
HAWAIIAN AIRLINES IS OFFERING
FREE FLIGHTS ARE MEDICAL
WORKERS.
THEY WANT TO COME HELP THOSE
HARD-HIT AREAS WITH COVID-19.
MY LOVE ORIGINAL RECIPE.
KFC.
THEY ARE GIVING AWAY A MILLION
PIECES OF CHICKEN TO THEIR
FRANCHISEES IN THE HOPES THAT
THEY WILL DISTRIBUTED TO THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
EASTERN AIRLINES PENNSYLVANIA,
NEARLY 6,000 AMERICANS WHO WERE
STRANDED ABROAD -- I KNOW FOR A
FACT THAT THE STATE DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN BRINGING PEOPLE BACK
AND WORKING AROUND-THE-CLOCK.
THEY’VE MADE IT HAPPEN.
CONGRATULATIONS TO
SECRETARY POMPEO AND HIS ENTIRE
TEAM.
AT BROOKS BROTHERS TO THE LIST
OF U.S. COMPANIES SHIFTING
PRODUCTION TO CREATE THESE
DESPERATELY-NEEDED MEDICAL
SUPPLIES.
THEY ARE GOING TO MANUFACTURE
150,000 MASKS PER DAY.
IF WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS THE
BEST IN AMERICA HERE.
IF THE OVERWHELMING NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE, 80F AND 90% OF AMERICANS
DOING WHATEVER THEY CAN DO.
THEY SEE THIS UNPRECEDENTED
SITUATION UNFOLDING, THEY ARE
STEPPING UP.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE’S A LOT OF
JACKASSES IN THE MEDIA MOB AND A
PSYCHOPATH IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
MORE CONCERNED WITH BLUDGEONING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ACTUALLY
HELPING IN THIS MOMENT OF
CRISIS.
IN THE MIDDLE OF A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY, THE MEDIA MOB
ACTIVELY TRYING TO SUPPRESS
INFORMATION THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS GIVING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
ONE FAR LEFT MEDIA GROUP HAS
ACTUALLY PETITIONED THE FCC TO
ACTUALLY CENSOR THE PRESIDENT’S
DAILY CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE
PRESSERS.
THEY DON’T WANT AMERICANS TO SEE
THE CRITICAL INFORMATION THAT
THEY ARE WANTING AND NEEDING FOR
THEIR FAMILIES.
THEY ARE NOT ALONE EITHER.
TAKE A LOOK, SOME OF THE WORST.
>> IF IT WERE UP TO ME, AND IT’S
NOT, I WOULD STOP PUTTING THOSE
BRIEFINGS ON MY TO BE BUT IF HE
KEEPS LYING LIKE HE HAS BEEN
EVERY DAY ON STUFF THIS
IMPORTANT, WE SHOULD, ALL OF US,
SHOULD START BROADCASTING IT,
HONESTLY, IT’S GOING TO COST
LIVES.
>> THIS IS HONESTLY ABOVE MY PAY
GRADE, I DON’T TAKE THE CALL BUT
IT SEEMS CRAZY TO ME THAT
EVERYONE IS STILL TAKING THEM
WHEN YOU HAVE THE MY FELLOW GUY
TALKING ABOUT READING THE BIBLE.
>> I’M NOT ACTUALLY SURE IF YOU
WANT TO BE HONEST THAT WE SHOULD
CARRY THE LIES.
I THINK WE SHOULD RUN SNIPPETS.
I THINK WE SHOULD DO IT
AFTERWARDS GET THE PERTINENT
POINTS TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
BECAUSE HE’S NEVER, EVER GOING
TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: THIS WEEK FAKE NEW
CNN AND BRASWELL RACHEL
MADDOW’S -- THANK GOD IT’S NOT
UP TO HER AND OF COURSE THE
STATE-RUN DEMOCRATIC SOCIAL
PARTY MSDN SEE BOWING TO
PRESSURE FROM THEIR CONSPIRACY
THEORIST HOST AND FREQUENTLY
THEY ARE CUTTING AWAY FROM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WHILE HE’S GIVEN IMPORTANT
INFORMATION, GIVING THE EDGE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DURING A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
PATHETIC, DESPICABLE, BUT SADLY
PROTECTABLE.
"NEW YORK TIMES" ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE, YOU SHOULD TRAVEL TO
CHINA ON FEBRUARY 5TH.
THAT’S BRILLIANT.
FEBRUARY 1ST, MR. PIMPLE, ARE
YOU READING YOUR OWN NEWSPAPER?
THEY ARE TELLING -- GET A GRIP,
THE FLU IS WAY WORSE THAN THE
CORONAVIRUS.
ACCORDING TO "THE BOSTON GLOBE"
THE PRESIDENT HAS BLOOD ON HIS
HANDS, OTHERS BASHING YOURS
TRULY CLAIMING WE HAVE BLOOD ON
OUR HANDS.
NOTHING BUT A LIE.
WE HAVE REPORTED THE FACTS
WITHOUT FEAR FROM DAY ONE, OUR
VERY FIRST INTERVIEW WITH
DR. FAUCI WAS ON JANUARY 27TH.
YOU CAN SEE IT ALL ON
Hannity.com BUT WE KNOW THE
MEDIA MOB IS WORKING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THEY ARE ONE AND THE SAME.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT HAVE LIGHT
FOR THREE AND A HALF STRAIGHT
YEARS.
YEP, THEY ARE STILL ADDED AND
TONIGHT, THE ACTIONS FROM SOME
TOP DEMOCRATS IS BEYOND UP
ORANGE.
HERE’S AN EXAMPLE, REMEMBER THIS
GUY?
THE CORRUPT CONGENITAL LIAR,
COMPROMISED ADAM SCHIFF?
RIGHT NOW IN THE MIDDLE OF A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY WE ARE STILL
RESPONDING, HE WANTS A 9/11
COMMISSION-STYLE REPORT ON HOW
THE PRESIDENT HANDLED THE
CORONAVIRUS ISSUE.
UNLIKE THE 9/11 COMMISSION
REPORTS, SCHIFF’S POLITICAL
WITCH HUNT WOULD NOT INVESTIGATE
THE ACTIONS OF CONGRESS, ONLY
TRUMP.
MEANWHILE, PELOSI HAS ALREADY
SET UP A COMMITTEE SOLELY
COMMITTED TO OVERSEE THE
PRESIDENT’S RESPONSE TO
CORONAVIRUS.
WHILE HE WAS DOING THE TRAVEL
BAN, LET’S SEE, YOU GUYS WERE
IMPEACHING HIM.
HOW MANY DEMOCRATS -- I WANT
EVERY DEMOCRAT TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION, IN RETROSPECT, WAS THE
PRESIDENTS TRAVEL BAN TEN DAYS
AFTER THE FIRST KNOWN CASE IN
THE U.S., WAS THAT THE RIGHT
CALL?
IN RETROSPECT?
APPOINTED JAMES CLYBURN TO LEAD
THE COMMITTEE.
REMEMBER HE’S THE GUY WHO STATED
HIS INTENTION TO USE THE CRISIS
WERE "TO RESTRUCTURE THINGS TO
FIT OUR VISION."
MOMENTS AGO THE PRESIDENT
RESPONDED, LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS NOT THE TIME FOR
POLITICS.
ENDLESS PARTISAN INVESTIGATIONS.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
HAVE ALREADY DONE AN
EXTRAORDINARY DAMAGE TO OUR
COUNTRY IN RECENT YEARS.
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
IT’S A WITCH HUNT AFTER
WITCH HUNT AFTER WITCH HUNT AND
IN THE END, THE PEOPLE DOING THE
WITCH HUNT HAVE BEEN LOOSING AND
THEY’VE BEEN LOSING BIOLOGIC,
CONDUCTING THESE PARTISAN
INVESTIGATIONS IN THE MIDDLE OF
A PANDEMIC, IT’S A REALLY BIG
WASTE OF VITAL RESOURCES, TIME,
ATTENTION, AND WE WANT TO FIGHT
FOR AMERICAN LIVES HIM AND TIME.
>> Sean: EVEN IN THE MIDDLE OF
A NATIONAL EMERGENCY, PANDEMIC,
DEMOCRATS, MEDIA MOB, THEY CAN’T
STOP THEIR COMPULSION AND HATRED
OF DONALD TRUMP BEYOND
DISGUSTING BEHAVIOR.
REMEMBER I WAS SAYING ALL THE
TIME, DONALD TRUMP CURED CANCER,
THEY WOULD WANT TO IMPEACH HIM.
WHAT THEY HAVE ENACTED THE
TRAVEL BAN?
A GOOD QUESTION FOR ANYBODY
RUNNING FOR OFFICE THIS COMING
NOVEMBER IN 215 DAYS FROM TODAY.
CAN THEY EVEN ADMIT THAT IT
SAVED COUNTLESS OF AMERICANS
FROM CONTRACTING THE DISEASE AND
EXPONENTIALLY MATHEMATICALLY
FROM DYING?
PELOSI IS NOT ALONE IN THIS
DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR.
NEW YORK SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER,
HE CAN’T STOP COMPLAINING
DESPITE THE MASSIVE AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE.
THERE’S NEVER BEEN AN EFFORT
LIKE THIS FOR ANY ONE STATE.
THE PRESIDENT HOW DIRECTING IT
ALL TO NEW YORK, THE EPICENTER
AND IT’S JUST NOT GOOD ENOUGH
FOR SCHUMER.
IN FACT, HE SENT A LETTER, HE
SENT THE PRESIDENT A LETTER
DEMANDING THAT HE APPOINT A
SENIOR MILITARY OFFICER TO LEAD
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT’S
LOGISTICAL RESPONSE.
THE PROBLEM IS, CHUCK IS NOT
PAYING ATTENTION.
THE PRESIDENT DID THAT A LONG
TIME AGO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SENATOR SCHUMER WROTE A
LETTER TODAY AND HE SAYS YOU
COULD PUT A MILITARY MAN IN
CHARGE AND I SAID, WELL, CHUCK,
IF YOU KNEW A LITTLE BIT MORE,
WE HAVE ONE OF THE MOST HIGHLY
RESPECTED PEOPLE IN THE
MILITARY, THE ADMIRAL, THIS IS
WHAT HE DOES TOO, VERY
PROFESSIONALLY, AND HE’S IN
CHARGE, BUT CHUCK DIDN’T KNOW
THAT.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT DOING A
TRAVEL BAN, QUARANTINES, AND
SCHUMER LEADING THE IMPEACHMENT.
ALSO SENT A LETTER TO SCHUMER
WRITING "THANK YOU FOR A
DEMOCRATIC PUBLIC RELATIONS
LETTER AND INCORRECT SOUND
BITES, WHICH ARE WRONG IN EVERY
WAY" AND THE PRESIDENT
CONTINUED, "IF YOU SPENT LESS
TIME ON YOUR RIDICULOUS
IMPEACHMENT OAKS AND INSTEAD
FOCUS ON HELPING THE PEOPLE IN
NEW YORK, THEN THE STATE WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN SO COMPLETELY
UNPREPARED FOR THIS INVISIBLE
ENEMY."
SPEAKING OF WHICH, THE PRESIDENT
HAD SOME STRONG WORDS FOR STATES
LIKE NEW YORK, THIS IS AN EPIC
FAIL, COMPLETELY UNPREPARED FOR
ANY KIND OF CATASTROPHE.
HOW COULD THAT BE?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE STATES SHOULD HAVE BEEN
BUILDING THEIR STOCKPILE.
WE HAVE A MOST 10,000 IN OUR
STOCKPILE AND WE’VE BEEN
BUILDING IT AND WE’VE BEEN
SUPPLYING IT BUT THE STATES
SHOULD BE BUILDING.
WE ARE A BACKUP.
WE ARE NOT AN ORDERING CLERK, WE
ARE A BACKUP AND WE’VE DONE AN
UNBELIEVABLE JOB.
IDEALLY THOSE STATES SHOULD HAVE
AT ALL OF THIS EQUIPMENT AND I
THINK THEY WILL NEXT TIME.
YOU HEARD THE CASE WHERE
THOUSANDS OF VENTILATORS COULD
HAVE BEEN HAD AT A VERY
INEXPENSIVE PRICE THREE YEARS
AGO.
AND A CERTAIN STATE DECIDED NOT
TO EXERCISE THAT RIGHT BECAUSE
THEY WANTED TO BUILD A ROAD
WHERE THEY WANTED TO BUILD
SOMETHING ELSE BECAUSE IT’S BIG
MONEY.
I THINK IT WAS A BILLION
DOLLARS.
IF YOU’RE TALKING A LOT OF
MONEY.
FOR SOMETHING THAT MAY NEVER
HAPPEN.
>> Sean: WAS LESS THAN
600,000, BUT THEY WERE SPENDING
750 ON A SOLAR PROJECT THAT WENT
BELLY UP.
90 MILLION ON A LIGHT BULB
PROJECT, BELLY UP, ANOTHER
600 MILLION THAT WENT BELLY UP.
THAT BRINGS US TO NEW YORK
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO, ANOTHER
CONSTANT COMPLAINER AND COMRADE
BILL de BLASIO, ANOTHER
COMPLAINER.
TONIGHT WE HAVE A CONFERENCE OF
TIMELINE DETAILING HOW
NEW YORK’S GOVERNMENT FAILED ITS
CITIZENS IN A SPECTACULAR
FASHION.
SADLY.
BY THE WAY, NEW YORKERS PAY MORE
FOR TAXES PER CAPITA THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE IN AMERICA.
LET’S GO WAY BACK TO NOVEMBER OF
2015.
THE REPORT THE PRESIDENT IS
REFERRING TO.
THE NEW YORK STATE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH, PAGE 30 OF THAT REPORT.
DURING A SEVERE INFLUENZA
PANDEMIC, THERE’S LIKELY TO BE A
PROJECTED SHORTFALL OF
VENTILATORS.
15,783.
ROUNDED OFF TO 16,000.
DURING PEAK WEEK DEMAND.
AFTER READING THIS REPORT,
CUOMO, THE GOVERNOR, PURCHASED
ZERO NEW VENTILATORS, ZERO.
NOT ONE.
INSTEAD, HE INSTRUCTED THE
COMMISSION TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO
RATION THE EXISTING 2,000
VENTILATORS.
THAT’S DERELICTION OF DUTY,
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE WASTED ALL OF
THESE MILLIONS -- HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON PROJECTS THAT ALL FAILED, BUT
IT GETS WORSE.
FLASH FORWARD TO THIS YEAR,
JANUARY 24TH.
CUOMO WAS TELLING HIS STATE THE
CORONAVIRUS RISK IS, TO
NEW YORK -- TO NEW YORKERS IS
LOW.
FEBRUARY 6TH, HE SAID THE FLU
WAS A MUCH GREATER RISK.
MARCH THE 1ST HE SAID THERE’S NO
REASON FOR UNDUE ANXIETY, THE
GENERAL RISK REMAINS LOW.
A FEW DAYS LATER, WELL, HE SAID
NEW YORK AND MANAGE THE
INCREASING SPREAD OF THE VIRUS.
THAT’S IN MARCH.
THIS GOT OUT IN MARCH.
HE WAS WRONG OVER AND OVER AGAIN
AND THE WORST PART IS HIS STATE
WAS PREPARED FOR NOTHING.
NUMBER ONE TARGET FOR TERRORISM
AND IF YOU HAVE A PANDEMIC OF
ANY KIND, NEW YORK, HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF PEOPLE,
10 MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
SMALLEST GEOGRAPHICAL AREA.
NEW YORK’S HEALTH CARE SYSTEM IS
SO OVERWHELMED, GET THIS,
CARDIAC ARREST VICTIMS WHOSE
HEARTS CANNOT BE RESTARTED AT
THE SCENE, THEY’RE NOT BEING
TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL AS IS
USUAL PROTOCOL.
NEW YORK POST BROKE THAT STORY
BECAUSE OF AN EXECUTIVE ORDER --
WHAT, WE NOW KNOW IN NEW YORK IF
YOU WANT TO TAKE THE POTENTIALLY
LIFE-SAVING TREATMENT WE HAVE
TALKED SO MUCH ABOUT, HYDROXY
CLERK WHEN, YOU HAVE TO GO TO A
HOSPITAL IN THE STATE OF
NEW YORK TO GET IT.
THAT’S A DUMB IDEA.
GOVERNOR CUOMO, THIS IS THE ONLY
STATE NOW DOING THIS.
OF MICHIGAN RESCINDED IT, NEVADA
RESCINDED A.
RESCIND ORDER, GOVERNOR.
ALLOWED NEW YORKERS TO GET THE
DRUG IF THEY CHOOSE AT A
PHARMACY AND STOP PUSHING PEOPLE
THAT DON’T NEED TO BE IN A
HOSPITAL INTO THE HOSPITAL
SYSTEM.
WITHOUT DONALD TRUMP’S HELP, IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN OVERRUN BY THIS
POINT.